how many of us still let our in-laws
tell us what we're doing for Christmas
how many of us let our boss determine
our self worth how many of us say yes to
every invitation because the world
revolves around us and without us the
whole world falls down a boundary is a
reverse Golden Rule a boundary is saying
I love others enough and I love myself
enough that I'm going to do what I need
to do to stay whole and well so that I
can go out and serve so I can go out and
love so I can be fully able to show up
when other people are speaking into your
life telling you what you're going to do
and when you're going to do it and how
you're going to do it your body will
sound the alarms because it recognizes
you're in the backseat of your own life
somebody else is driving and so if you
want to live a life free from anxiety
you have to choose boundaries